no jimmy you didn't sin you just didn't
have a spare tire okay
jimmy swagger will atone for his sins by
publishing a magazine called repent
house thank you
thank you jimmy
thank you
little pictures a little scratch and
sniffle help me now and remember there's
no such word as audit in the bible okay
in order not to violate the writer's
strike
i will be channeling the spirit of
george jessel
continue
to present the best director award yeah
if we can have a moment please
before i do that i just want to know why
are there no jewish evangelists someone
comes up going my leg he goes your leg
my arm i can't play tennis okay
let us continue
because that award was so close all
those calls to entertainment tonight at
50 cents a pop damn okay
here we go i will now channel the spirit
of george jessel channeling that strange
thing where you usually sound like
you've swallowed a vibrator here we go
what can you say about a director that
he would believe himself
director from the latin word director
meaning he who cashes the first check
thank you
there are some i can't quite turn up
it's too hard sorry shirley i'm sorry
babe
it is an honor to present the award for
best director
what are directors besides people who
wear down jackets and baseball caps
does woody allen dream in black and
white and if so does ted turn to buy
them and color them in
jade
who didn't give you the crayons as a boy
directors are very very unusual people
there's also categories of directors
there's the just the plain director
simple there's the actor director must
be very hard it must be my like making
love to sybil it's like it's good for me
not for me okay
there's the writer director who if he
goes on strike who stays i don't know if
he fires him does he have to file a
grievance i can't oh too late okay
is there the writer director producer
one of the few creatures on the planet
who can blow smoke up his own ass
thank you
right now the sensor is sitting at home
going oh man do that
you're getting calls the lines are
lining up 1 800 robin 1-800 robin
but we know we're talking jack i'm
trying for you man i'm here with you
he's there the glasses are working dude
okay
we must present this award because it's
a very very special award
i give it out
with the knowledge that it's going to
some very very wonderful people the
nominees for best achievement in
directing are
blank
oh obviously uh there we go oh god the
guy in the camera bernardo bertolucci
for last emperor one of ronald reagan's
favorite film
john borman for hope and glory
they all don't seem to know how to look
through the lens look the cap is still
on
rusty holster for my life as a dog
norman jewison for moonstruck
also the academy is providing along with
the oh sorry one more
this is our adrian line for fatal
attraction
he has also been signed to do a sequel
financial attraction the jessica hahn
story
and the winner is and the academy along
with the oscar this year is giving out a
green card
the winner is
fernando bertolucci for the last temple
so
thank you it was a very long way from
down there
as an italian as a european
the academy awards
has always seemed to me like a distant
ceremony something fascinating but very
remote something i really didn't belong
to
then one day
the last emperor got nine nomination and
everything changed immediately
um
i became immediately a kind of oscar
victim i started to learn the rule of
the game
and
um to take
um to
to check the odds
to
start the colitis
and
the beta blockers the internal all these
things i mean
i became a kind of oscar victim and
i want to do a chinese call tower to the
to the academy because
this is one of the strongest emotions of
my life and i can't hide it
and i want to thank
the chinese who allowed me to shoot in
the beautiful
country
and
the chinese emperor john lone the
chinese empress john chen and
all the wonderful
people
who gave him their creativity in front
behind and around the camera i can't
name all of them they're wonderful
and
i just i was just thinking that if
new york
is the big apple
to me oliver tonight is the big nipple
thank you very much
hi i'm betty murphy
why even go into this let's have a big
round of applause for all the winners
tonight huh
i know how it feels to be a loser i know
you've got your touch on and you feel
real stupid right now
for the losers you got to make them feel
good at first when they uh came to me
and they said they wanted me to uh
present the award for best picture my
management came and they told me that
the academy had picked me in and my
first reaction was to say no i ain't
going and i said my but why have a white
manager inside us
and i said
i said i'm not going because they
haven't recognized black people in the
motion picture you said what are you
talking about black people want oscars i
said well black actors and actresses
have won oscars throughout 60 years was
like uh i think i'm happy mcdaniel's won
the first one then um cindy poitier won
one and lou gossett won and i'll
probably never want to oscar for saying
this but hey what the heck i got to say
um
actually i might have been in trouble
because the way it's been going is about
every 20 years we get one so we ain't do
for about to about 2004 so
by that time it's all blown over i said
i wasn't going and my man said you just
have to go you can't snub the academy so
i came down here to give the award i
said but i just feel that we have to be
recognized as people i just want you
know i'm gonna give this award but black
people will not ride the caboose of
society and we will not bring up the
rear anymore i want you to recognize us
he said well fine it's done i said when
do i have to be they said well you don't
have to get there to about nine or ten
because it's the last award of the
evening
and in keeping with a great old
hollywood tradition the best picture
nominees the best pictures are
broadcast news
in which showbiz comes to the newsroom
james l brooks producer
fatal attraction
in which adultery comes to scare you to
death stanley r jaffe and sherry lansing
producers
hope and glory
in which the second world war comes to
england john borman producer
the last emperor
in which the modern era comes to china
jeremy thomas producer
and the winner is
oh i'm sorry well i know before all of
you
moonstruck in which fashion comes to
brooklyn patrick palmer and norman
jewison producers
are they anymore
they play their thing like
uh and the winner is
the last emperor jeremy thomas producer
i must say this is a truly imperial
evening for me
and for everybody who worked very hard
with me on this picture
um i'd like to thank about 30 000 people
who
helped us make this picture
it took four years to make
and um
was very very rewarding
um
this award from the academy
is a real affirmation for me that
independent cinema
can be epic and
both popular and i hope that this oscar
will mean that many many more people can
see this picture in america
um of course i want to thank
bernardo for inviting me on this
incredible voyage of discovery and thank
you all very much this is an incredible
moment thank you
what a night good night everybody thanks
for coming
so
so
so
all eligible academy members are asked
to vote for nominations for best picture
other nominations are voted by members
who are specialists in each field
winners are decided by vote of the
entire membership only members who
attend special streams may vote in the
documentary short subjects and foreign
language film categories
results of the secret boating are known
only to the independent accounting firm
of bryce waterhouse until the sealed
envelopes are opened on air
this is hank sims speaking
you